sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono
video sono fa vj e ci sono tanti susan
simulator non so perché scusate dire che
se c'è una felpa inguardabile ma ti
posso un freddo della madonna quindi
barbabietola che ho ragazzi rimasti che
avevo fatto le operazioni quelle del
trapianto di cuore di rene in corridoi
adesso ci provo pro loco il trapianto di
cervello
io queste in corridoio ragazze non aveva
mi spiegate perchè cazzo uno si fa
un'operazione in corridoio con una sedia
a rotelle in retromarcia iniziare perché
sono un inizio più ad ora che ascolta è
col martello il martellone il martel
niente una sega non si sa prendere
niente mi spiace zio ma ti devo spaccare
il trani o pugni perché non riesco a
prendere il martello tipo paglia no no
la tazza la tazza forse con la tazza yo
yo una scena del genere non l'ho mai
aimi che queste scene non si vedono
tutti i giorni e già spaccata e cos'è sì
sì sì sì sì no no e allora sei stronzo
che no
9 [__] tre minuti per prendere un
martello epico che nessuno in questa
testa bellissima [__] amica
ragazzi ci sto mettendo gli anni gli
anni per affrescare nuovo cioè mi sembra
normale ma i ragazzi mi sto tipo
tagliando le vene non si sa come però
ceduto sangue sul polso mia mostra
operazione prima possibile perché non ne
posso già più affanculo al martello può
prendere il posto tanto non ti serve
essere ecco perfetto stavolta zione che
no non oltre il trapano sulle ruote no
come faccio a tagliare col cucchiaio il
cucchiaio buon appetito ragazzi adesso
si mangia serve il cervello duomo che è
gustoso ragazzi il cibo negli ospedali
fa veramente schifo quindi mi mangio io
faccio da me ovviamente ci mancava che
fossi trovata
sì sì sì sì sì no no non è sei stronzo
se la droga non avesse psico così si
impugnano le forbici amico mio hai preso
al piano piano piano però ok ok per
questo si droga mentre prende gli
attrezzi non è colpa mia
ok no no sì come non presso frega se non
so come ho fatto a prendere il martello
ma non importa più alta zio ceo tra io
tra l'altro impugni martelli così perché
è giusto ascoltare chi per caso dai che
ti sto facendo più intelligente di
com'eri prima di la verità quebec e ebbe
proprio 6 mal di testa moment act volta
bel cervellino tiene che ti va di uscire
perfetto va bene anche così c'è qualcuno
adesso mi dovete spiegare da dove li sta
accadendo da dietro la testa prova beh
allora ragazzi non hanno trovato un
cervello quindi li metto una tazza tatro
minimi si è incastrata la tazza in mezzo
alle dita qualcuno adesso mi spiega come
sia scientificamente possibile una cosa
così diano io non ce la farò perché
tanto mi morirà prima ma ci provo
merda sì sì il cervello ragazzi da the
date vincere non c'è il cervello
[__] semi muore così mi già la
siringa
no no no no no mi muore mimo remi muore
mi moreno morire non morire una palla da
basket dalla mette in testa al posto del
cervello ti giuro che sappiano io adesso
prendo la siringa questo schifo e lo
metto sul tavolo
devo prendere la siringa e la metto
sultano la prende la cristo non c'è
fottutamente verso come cazzo fai
incastrarti il pollice in un cranio come
qualcuno ha voglia di darvi un martello
non so qualcosa tipo per spacca grazie è
molto gentile ma [__] martello
martello martello manco per il plan e
servirebbe alla questo lo prendo la
metto qui ragazzi mi metto tutti gli
attrezzi buoni qua sopra
sì perché io perché mi si incastrano le
cose tra le perché ci sono anche ha
drogato o un martello schifoso mio dio
per favore sì sì ci ho fatto perché
datevi un cervello reagan datemi una
bottiglia va bene uguale tonto e stupido
vendere datemi un pennarello lo metto
possibile sì se vivi e si più
intelligente di prima mi come il
cervello di è diventato optional perché
non l'ha perso da possiamo mica mezz'ora
30 adesso mi chiami scoprendo si veloce
velo al contrario ragazzi è stato è
stato devastante giuro tutti ragazzi
proprio vedere se riesco a fare qualcosa
quale altra operazione quella degli
occhi mi chiede gli occhi trapiantati in
corridoio del re epico già quella del
cervello è stata quanto strana però
vabbè quanto sei film agiato tirargli
pugni in faccia per aprire lo sto
stordendo di brutto da m i cani scusate
voti fa spaccarli perfetto perfetti o in
un'operazione chirurgica il primo passo
è quello di spaccare la mascherina con
una scelta è giusto mi serve un bisturi
qualcuno voglia di inviarmi qualcosa non
so neanche un game boy piuttosto grazie
ai ragazzi cotton fioc in gioca chi cosa
cazzo servono spiegatemelo non sentirà
giuro che non sentirai niente scusa
ragazzi non so se precisamente si doveva
fare non mi ricordo per ora cosa mi dice
che stiamo facendo giusto e bello che
ascolta mentre tu giochi colto nuovo
giocattolino io te ne trova un altro
ovviamente un altro occhio non si sente
solo solo che devo trovarlo no no no no
no no sì no porca ladra
[Musica]
mi fate togliere questi schifo ecco
perché grazie ad esso uno sguardo molto
molto più sexy di prima adesso lo prenda
tipo pugni in faccia finché non mi sputi
gli occhi credo prima di continuare una
bella siringa dell'orecchio perfetto si
torni a sentire tutto si sono fatta
piano piano
[Musica]
e se uno è andato io te lo dico sei un
figo ma figo tanto calmo si ragazzi non
chiedetemi come ma ce la sto facendo
solo mentali con i nuovi credo e non mi
ricordo non prenderli così si perfetta
11 posso per favore grazie
come promesso si sa che bello che c'è
chi ammira di merda giolica [__]
se ho fatto lega è stato non scappare
con i bisturi non ho scampo che stai
tranquillo non scappo mai visto è stato
magico lega pro ho avuto io ma dagli
occhi allentato 13 13 minuti di
operazione ha mai fatto una cosa così
probabilmente un'operazione vera di oggi
sarebbe durata un pò di meno stavolta è
durato un casino direi che posso
concludere che l'episodio ragazzi anche
se mi manca che non ho ancora visto
all'opera i denti cioè il loonie
premiato dentista saprò fare anche
questo ragazzo d'accordo ragazzini che
posso non credere che il video teatro è
bellissimo l'omino col palloncino non
avevo ancora visto i ragazzi servizio è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a pagani facebook è come la vita
tratta una descrizione non se volessi
destinazioni ci vedono proseguito belle
ragazze